[موسيقى]
الشغله اللي سويتها وندمان عليها صراحه
اختي حبت واحد وهو اجى خطبها ورا يتزوجها
بس ابن عمي ناهي عليها وهي بتريد ابن عمي
تعالي شردت ويا هذا اللي تحبه
فابوي واماني والعشيره قرروا ولازم نقتلها
واني ظليت شهر ادور عليها الى عن لقيتها
وقتلتها ما كان عندي حل ثاني
لان اذا ما اقتلها اصير عار على العشيره
وهذا القرار ما بيه مجال للنقاش
شو تقرر العشيره اني لازم انفذ اولا موضوع
القتل هو موضوع مرفوض مرفوض دينيا يعني
حتى في الشريعه الاسلاميه هذه الجريمه من
الجرائم التي تشدد فيها
الشرع الاسلامي في موضوع الاثبات
ولم ياخذها على علاتها فهو مرفوض من ناحيه
الشرع ومرفوض من ناحيه القانون موضوع
القتل مهما كان الدافع ومهما كان الموضوع
حياه الانسان اثمن شيء في الوجود
[موسيقى]
يعني الطفل اولا راح يتربع على قضيه
الثائر يتربع على قضيه روح الانتقام يتربى
على قضيه انه الاعراف العشائريه هي اللي
تحكمه واللي هي يجب ان تخليه في مسيرته من
يكبر هذا غلط هذا غلط هذه يعني ثقافه
الناس توجهاتهم استقرار الناس مرهونه
بالخلافات بين هذه العشيره وهاي العشيره
وانا اعتقد مو مساله اصبحت عشائر وانما
تستثمر من خلال نزاعات سياسيه تتوجه الى
هذا الجانب